back in Washington President Trump
continues to face questions about the
ongoing Russia investigation the
president has expressed frustration over
Special Counsel Robert Miller's probe
and two-word Attorney General Jeff
Sessions CBS News justice reporter Paula
Reid has been tracking the investigation
and is here with more Paula good morning
good morning okay this week we learned
about Paul Manafort George papadopolis
what can you tell us about the scope of
this investigation and where is it
heading
we knew that Paul Manafort was likely
under investigation for possible money
laundering tax crimes and not filling
out the proper paperwork for his foreign
lobbying activity and we knew all this
because we were keeping an eye on who
was testifying before the grand jury but
what we didn't know and caught us
totally by surprise was Papadopoulos and
this was a surprise to everyone and what
that tells us is that Muller has some
lines of inquiry and is collecting
evidence that suggests that there were
contacts between the Trump campaign and
Russia so it really tells everyone that
Muller is only letting on only letting
us see what he wants people to see
President Trump meanwhile is painting
Papadopoulos as a low-level player so
how significant could he be here do you
think even if he is a low-level player
again this is someone who possesses
emails allegedly and has communications
with higher-level campaign officials and
that could potentially cause a problem
again it's easy to distance yourself
from Paul manna for its personal
business dealings it's easy to distance
yourself from a low-level campaign
staffer but as we saw in court when this
plea plea was issued it is clear at
prosecutors say that he has evidence
emails and other communications with
higher-level staffers and not the
problem well he's known as what is a
proactive cooperator which means what
exactly
some people have interpreted this to
mean that oh he wore a wire but I've
talked to sources no one has confirmed
the wire but what people also point out
to me is in this day and age you don't
necessarily need to wear a wire to trip
someone up emails text messages there's
so much electronic communication that
you can collect that can be used as
evidence what do you think the
significance of the use of that term
Paula was when when they announced these
charges let's look at the choreography
here on Monday nothing is a mistake here
everything is a very well choreographed
message to the other people
under scrutiny and again seeing a
proactive coordinator I was seeing a
proactive cooperator I think that's a
clear message that he has been
cooperating and he will continue to
cooperate and that's probably going to
concern anyone who was speaking with him
in the last few months who had no idea
and then you're gonna start wondering
well who else might be proactively
cooperating right the chilling effect if
you're an administration
speaking of which Attorney General Jeff
Sessions is now under scrutiny for tests
for testimony he made under oath
regarding communications between the
administration and the Russians and the
campaign and the Russians has he tested
has he spoken to Muller's investigative
team he has not I've confirmed that he
has not been asked to testify he
mentioned that when he was up on the
hill but I've confirmed that is still
the case and that should be a possible
point of concern for him because it
suggests that he is not just a mere
witness to that possible obstruction of
justice in the firing of James Comey and
he could be a focus of the overall
investigation into this question of
conspiracy or collusion Wow that's a big
deal it is a big deal it hasn't been a
great week for Jeff Sessions now on this
issue if some people are alleging that
he perjured himself I think people just
have to ask themselves would you
remember something that was suggested by
a low-level campaign staffer a year
prior a campaign staffer who was in the
room with the president that was he was
but it when you go back and look at
sessions testimony it doesn't appear to
be a clear case of perjury
of course sessions has had a tough year
in terms of his congressional testimony
for failing to disclose meetings he had
with ambassador kis lyac and I think
most people would agree that you are
much more likely to remember a meeting
you had than a meeting that someone
suggested Paula Reid Thank You Paula